In Iraq, government forces clear areas around Fallujah...
...after launching an assault to retake the city,...
...tightening their siege on the Islamic State.
In Vietnam, US President Barack Obama calls for territorial disputes...
...in the South China Sea to be "resolved peacefully".
Authorities in Greece are bussing thousands of migrants...
...away from the makeshift camp at Idomeni on the Macedonian border.
In Ukraine, Kiev says a surge in fighting between pro-Russian separatists...
...and Ukrainian government forces in the country's east...
...kills seven Ukrainian soldiers.
And finally from Belgium, police clash with protesters,...
...firing water cannons at a huge demonstration in Brussels...
...against the center-right government's austerity measures.